STUDENT: How is the British context different for being in public life and being a person of faith? Because I know that when people
that you were doing-- taking this project on after leaving office, there was surprise that all of a sudden
Tony Blair's a man of faith.
But you said,
"Originally, oh I've always been a man of faith," but
there was always some element, that maybe you chose your
timing wisely. Just curious about what that experience was like.
BLAIR: Well, first of all,
I think next seminar we'll have the wife [laughs].
She seems a saintly person.
I...
I meanI mean, it was difficult-- actually what Tony said chimed
with me.
there is a sense in which people could use God in a political debate
that really,
if you actually are someone of faith, really makes you uncomfortable.
And also, the British are a bit reserved about these things, frankly. So
-- the moment at the end of one speech-- I wanted to end the speech
by saying,
"God bless Britain,"
you know? And I tell you, that was
"You can't possibly say that, Prime Minister,"
said a senior civil servant. I said, "Well, why not?"
One of them said, "Oh, for goodness' sake, Prime Minister, this isn't America, you know."
So
there's always-- I think a--
a natural reserve that there is about it.
But I actually-- I didn't hide the fact. I used to go to church every week and was often photographed there.
But I actually had a reluctance
to talk about
God, but-- I mean,
I think, for me,
the global poverty issue particularly was very linked with my religious--
religious belief and faith.
But it was difficult, 'cause the trouble is--
you know, the
problem is, in politics-- this is true, incidentally, in the debate
about globalization.
And it's
where sometimes there is an impatience
from political people with religious people,
because actually the decisions can be difficult, you know?
And sometimes religious people can be on the side of...
"If you only
cared more, then
it would be a lot easier." You know, if you're a political leader, and you're in this situation taking
decisions, you're saying,
"Yeah, I care, but I mean--
it's this way or that way, so which way do I go?"
And you know, it can be very--
so that, I think, is part of the discourse
that's important. And I think one of the things that I think
actually--
faith can
challenge political leadership,
but also an engagement between faith and political leadership also allows that to be a bit of
a two-way process.
So far example, in globalization, I've found the hardest thing, actually,
with the church groups on
the debt cancellation and the G8 agenda in 2005, which is a broad agenda,
not just about aid and debt but also about
governance--
you know, I would say to them, "I'm sorry, we're putting governance on the table, 'cause some of
these countries are corrupt and that's their problem.
It's not 'cause I'm not giving 'em enough money;
the money that is being given ends up someplace in Switzerland. So that's not right."
Or alternatively,
and more difficult in a way,
you would have a fierce debate about free trade.
Because there were elements within the global poverty movement that said," Free trade
is a snare and delusion for the poor, it
actually increases poverty."
And I would say, "Well, hang on a minute. That is a technical
and political and economic question and we've gotta debate that.
I'm not prepared just
to kind of accept that
just because you're a religious person you can say that to me and I've got to accept that as the morally
right position."
So I think,
you know, there's that as well,
that interacts with all this. But I
agree with Tony in the sense that
I think it would be
really tragic
if the faith part got squeezed out of public life.
In the sense that people actually felt embarrassed about
their faith.
And also, it would end up actually being
quite dishonest, because in fact,
there are a lot of people in the world of politics, and amazing numbers of them, actually,
in senior political positions who do believe very strongly.
Doesn't mean it always makes them better political leaders,
but it's important about them as human beings.
STUDENT: And I think it is those who use faith in a sort of pandering way
are the ones that are sort of making it divisive
and make non-religious people sort of impatient, as you say, with religion.
I think that this issue is actually something that we should
talk about more broadly
in this course. I mean, it's really important for getting the sort of
non-religious people in bed with those of faith. Environmental groups that are on the left,
religious groups working with Rick Warren, people like that--
you know, how do you get there, more broadly, is a really interesting question and an important question.
well